welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and The Last of Us on HBO
shocked fans of the video game with its
faithful accuracy to the series at times
even replicating the game's dialogue and
scenes shot for shot and we loved it but
changes are inevitable and necessary
when switching mediums So today we're
going to be looking at the show's top
three biggest changes from the game and
why they were made spoilers for the
entire first game and first season of
the show ahead number three the changes
to Joel's character it's no surprise
that in the video games Joel has
superhuman levels of invulnerability
with combat being such a central aspect
of the game he has to be able to take a
bunch of bullets no problemo heal it
will and run Crouch and parkour to his
heart's content but in real life if you
take five bullets to the chest a bandage
around the arm probably won't do the
trick so the realistic effects of Joel's
age and damaging life experiences were
taken into account prior to the show
airing co-showrunner Craig Mason
revealed the toll that Joel's life would
take on his health saying he's hard of
hearing on one side because of a gunshot
his knees hurt every time he stands up I
guess there's a tone where Tom Cruise
can do anything but I like my
middle-aged people middle-aged he also
later said 55 year olds can't crash for
more than like three minutes tops and
then their back gives out so his words
not mine I think middle-aged people are
strong and capable and could do anything
they put their minds to but I'm also
never gonna grow old so but we see all
this realistic human fragility in things
like Joel's Knuckles staying injured and
him only having finite energy which
makes injuries that much more serious
but there's a lot more to the choice to
up Joel's vulnerability than that after
all a lot of the combat was cut in the
game to opt for relationship instead and
this is where we see the real toll of
Joel's Health in action Joel's physical
limitations make him terrified that
he'll be unable to protect Ellie he
begins having panic attacks that amplify
that fear and when he's desperately
trying to convince Tommy to take her
because he thinks she'll be safer with
him he stresses his physical
shortcomings saying he was too slow
in-depth to hear that guy that Ellie had
to kill that he freezes in fear and that
Tommy is younger than him and still
strong Joel's vulnerability which first
manifests physically and then
emotionally make him a much more
relatable and empathetic character and
allows for touching moments that we
didn't get in the game like this
confession to Tommy sometimes times when
you love a show or movie it's not enough
to have seen it you need some merch to
commemorate the occasion and nerd riots
got you covered if the finale of The
Last of Us left you hungry for more pick
up a lunch of us tea available in cream
or black featuring the logo of Todd's
Steakhouse from episode 8 of the series
don't eat there though just don't do
that unless you're a cannibal in which
case Bon Appetit baby if you're stoked
for the upcoming John Wick movie nerd
ride has a whole line of John Wick
shirts to make you feel like you've got
to see it at the high table there's the
Baba yagati a gun Chuck's tea and a tea
for the high table itself proclaiming I
have served I will be of service get
them now and you'll be able to wear them
to opening night and then also the next
weekend when you see John MC chapter
four for the second time and of course
if you're obsessing over the Mandalorian
right now there's a whole line I'm in a
merch in the way collection with teas
beanies hats and even stuff for kids to
get your hands on the merch you need
head to nerdyright.shop today join the
riot over at nerd riot.shop number two
Sam Sam's character changed quite a bit
in the transition from game to TV so one
at a time let's look at each change and
how and why it came about the first
change is that Sam is significantly
younger in the show in the show he's
eight years old and in the games he's 13
about a year younger than Ellie making
Sam younger created the opportunity for
someone to look up to Ellie like she
looked up to Joel the age difference
also allows Ellie to feel more of a
sense of protectiveness and
responsibility for Sam being the older
one it makes the pain of not being able
to protect him in the end that much
worse and arguably UPS the pain on the
audience's end too since he's just a kid
another change they made was making Sam
deaf in the show Neil druckman and Craig
Mason said in HBO is The Last of Us
podcast that there were a few reasons
for this one was that it differentiated
their relationship from Joel's and
Ellie's more scenes with Henry and Sam
were inherently more quiet and intimate
and not being able to hear the dialogue
also made the audience become more
engaged in those scenes as well another
was that it created a larger Reliance on
his brother for Sam and likewise a
bigger need to protect Sam for Henry and
sharing a language in a world where it
would be extremely uncommon to come
across someone who also spoke ASL only
serves to strengthen their already
strong familial Bond it also
inadvertently led to further
representation on the show and chose a
post-apocalyptic World from yet another
perspective that the audience might not
have even considered finally Sam having
leukemia is unique to the show as we
find out in episode 5 Henry ratted out
the location of the leader of the Kansas
City Rebels to fedra in exchange for
medication for Sam's leukemia Henry and
Sam service foils for Joel and Ellie and
giving Sam's situation life or death
Stakes creates a parallel between the
choice Henry makes to put his brother
above the group and Jules decision to
save Ellie over potentially saving
Humanity there are other smaller changes
with Henry and Sam but maybe that's for
another video number one bill and Frank
Bill and Frank's story was by and large
the biggest shock that fans of the game
got when they tuned into episode so
three and not because Bill was gay that
was the case in the games too but in the
game bill is a Brash crash survivalist
who lives on his own when Ellie and Joel
find Bill they're looking for a car
battery and the following gameplay is
action-packed as the three of them gun
their way through hordes of infected in
search of that battery they arrive at a
house where Joel and Bill discover
Frank's Body who has decided to end his
life via hanging after being bitten
despite being Bill's partner Joel has
never met or heard of Frank but finds a
letter from him in the same house in
which Frank says some pretty harsh
things towards Bill including that he
hated the town and Bill's gut and would
rather die trying to leave than spend
another day with him Bill reacts coldly
to the letter and when they get the
battery working and Joel and Ellie leave
Bill is still very much alive and that's
the last we see of him so you might
understand why the show was a pretty big
shift but why did they decide to change
this section of the game to instead
focus on the couple's life together and
alter Bill's fate druckman and Mason
gave several reasons for the changes one
of the more straightforward answers is
that the action-packed gameplay just
didn't work as well for the television
medium and the first couple of episodes
were so go go that they felt like they
should take a breather this episode and
explore a happier story amidst all this
tragedy don't get me wrong it's still
extremely Bittersweet but as bill says
in the episode this isn't the tragic
suicide at the end of the play then
saying I'm old I'm satisfied and you
were my purpose their story of falling
in love and choosing to die on their own
terms is a success story in this world
and show some light moments in this
otherwise Grim atmosphere and Bill's
relationship with Frank provided an
opportunity to instead explore the
larger theme that they wanted to focus
on for the show love and the beauty pain
and inherent danger that comes from it
and in turn
men in the game
in the game lives on in the game
druckman amazing we're constantly
exploring the question what is this life
for and how best can we live it and in
the game who knows how fulfilling Bill's
life was living by himself with the one
person he cared about having died and
honestly players of the game weren't all
that invested and if Bill was happy or
not because
he was kind of a dick in the game hey
Bobby Fischer don't touch anything on
that board he mainly served as a sort of
comedic relief but I feel like a lot of
people read Frank's letter and were like
yeah I get it and then drove off into
the sunset without a second thought so
why not instead opt for an incredibly
moving storyline that really leaves you
thinking as druckman said on the HBO
podcast the gain of the change
outweighed the cost another reason for
the change was that it was part of what
ultimately led to Joel's final decision
in the season bill is a lot like Joel
both have a healthy dose of skepticism
and distrust from the outside world and
are only concerned about protecting the
one person they love and both of them
get more and more afraid as their love
grows Bill apologizes for growing older
faster than Frank and is terrified that
it means he won't be able to protect him
likewise when Joel is trying to convince
Tommy to take Ellie a big part of his
fear stems from feeling like he's
getting older and weaker Frank and Ellie
meanwhile are their counterparts in that
they want to share their light with
others and hold much more hope in their
hearts for the world bill can't live
without Frank in the same way that Joel
can't live without Ellie and it's not a
coincidence that in Bill's letter to
Joel he says that men like them have a
job to save the ones they love and God
help any [__] who might stand
in their way while Bill might have been
talking about Tess his message planted a
seed in Joel's head to protect and save
Ellie at all costs and that's
unfortunately all the changes I have
time to cover today there are obviously
many more differences between the game
and the show and if you want a part two
let us know comments until then you can
follow me on Twitter at it's anavanston
and follow And subscribe to new
rockstars at new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love later
[Music]